what people talk about for me I find
racism to be an insult because people
look at the skin the color of my skin
and they assume I'm lower than what I am
actually but what no they don't no they
actually do they actually do very but
coming from the two girls that brought
up race though that's the thing they
brought up R because race immediately
the show been going on 5 minutes youing
up black never never in my mind was like
question ask you a question um you said
like they who is they uh just overall
The General population in this country
at least would you say like everyone
would you say like everyone in this room
I don't think that's true I don't think
that's true in London I I'll explain to
you why I'll explain to you why they
hear my accent a lot of the time they
see my my skin tone I who wait people
just people in general I get so I I Met
You in London so I'm asking you like
they is that this this room is that like
everyone in here just met you today they